The reviews for Martin Scorsese's The Irishman
are in, and they're about as fantastic as
reviews can get.
Based on Charles Brandt's 2004 book I Heard
You Paint Houses, The Irishman stars Robert
De Niro as former mafioso and alleged hitman
Frank "The Irishman" Sheeran, who details
the dirty deeds he did while working for the
Bufalino crime family.
And there's particular focus on his involvement
in the disappearance and purported murder
of International Brotherhood of Teamsters
leader Jimmy Hoffa, played by Al Pacino.
The Irishman had its world premiere at the
57th New York Film Festival on September 27th,
2019, when critics fell head over heels for
it.
As of September 30th, The Irishman stands
at a flawless 100 percent approval rating
on Rotten Tomatoes.
Writing for IndieWire, Eric Kohn said of the
legendary director's latest,
"It takes less than five minutes to establish
The Irishman in Martin Scorsese's unmistakable
voice [...] The mood is at once taut and funny,
the essence of Scorsese's ability to humanize
the mob as prickly macho men just a few notes
shy of lovable.
In that fundamental disconnect — between
endearing people and the psychotic world they
represent — the movie presents a fascinating
onramp to America's obsession with organized
crime."
Kohn added that The Irishman is bursting with
"Scorsese's trademark style" and proves that
the director is, quote, "more alive than ever."
At The Movie Minute, Joanna Langfield wrote,
"Scorsese's mob epic demands and commands.
Confident enough to play with traditional
storytelling as well as cutting edge technology,
this is thrilling work from artists at their
prime.
[...] It's a marvel to watch the piece as
a whole, with its shifting tones, laugh out
loud funny breaks, and its sneaky, very human
heartbeat."
J. Don Birnam at Splash Report says that there's
more to The Irishman than meets the eye, writing,
"As with everything Scorsese touches, The
Irishman is plenty more than just a criminal's
biography.
Like many of his other films, it is a reflection
on human nature, on whether and how greed,
loyalty, betrayal, and regret, drive a life.
It is also, more fundamentally, an aging director's
look back with nostalgia at his own work,
at forgotten episodes in American history,
and about the meaning not just of life but
of humanity itself."
Slashfilm's Chris Evangelista called The Irishman
a "funny, melancholy" masterpiece in his review,
writing,
"This is not Goodfellas.
This is not Casino.
This is Scorsese at his most reflective, crafting
a masterwork that finds the filmmaker reflecting
on everything he's done, and what it's all
amounted to.
The results are breathtaking, and one of Martin
Scorsese's very best films."
The stellar cast of The Irishman received
high praise from critics, the vast majority
of whom felt each star turned in career-best
performances.
Vulture critic David Edelstein was impressed
by the major players in The Irishman, but
was completely floored by Joe Pesci as Russell
Bufalino.
Edelstein wrote in his review,
"I heard all sorts of huzzahs about Pacino
— and he is wonderful — but it's Pesci
who thrilled me to the core."
"He likes to talk, don't he?"
Matt Zoller Seitz of RogerEbert.com wrote
that The Irishman solidifies De Niro as, quote,
"one of the great scene-stealing straight
men" in film history, while Vogue's Taylor
Antrim said that "Pacino is just a scenery-chewing
riot as Hoffa."
AV Club's A.A.
Dowd commended both Scorsese's direction and
De Niro's enduring acting chops in writing
that the filmmaker, quote, "brings out a subtle
agony from De Niro one might have assumed
the actor could no longer summon."
"What, you want to know if I did it or not?"
Stephanie Zacharek at TIME Magazine felt similarly,
writing,
"De Niro gives his best performance in years,
with zero mugging or scowling — his Frank
is a man of action who's so busy doing bad
stuff, he barely has time to think."
Some may be wary of The Irishman after hearing
that it clocks in at a staggering 209 minutes,
but most critics have promised that the hefty
runtime is part of what makes the film so
special.
As The New Yorker's Richard Brody wrote,
"It runs a minute shy of three and a half
hours, and I wouldn't wish it any shorter."
Brody certainly wasn't the only one who felt
this way about The Irishman's runtime.
At AV Club, A.A.
Dowd said,
"This is a remarkably brisk three-and-a-half
hours — Scorsese, at a ripe 76, still directs
with the energy of a hungry young filmmaker,
his command of montage yanking the audience
forward from scene to scene."
Over at Vox, Alissa Wilkinson argued that,
quote, "the near-bagginess of the film is
part of its initial charm."
She continued,
"The Irishman's long arc (which involves the
use of largely unobtrusive de-aging technology)
means the film follows Frank and his associates
long past when the movie usually ends, with
triumph or failure.
The film instead takes a distinct turn away
from rat-a-tat plotting and revenge toward
a frankly stunning, contemplative movement."
Speaking of the digital de-aging in The Irishman
— used to make De Niro, Pesci, and Pacino
look decades younger — many critics agree
that while it can briefly take viewers out
of the film, the technology only adds to the
story.
Stephanie Zacharek wrote,
"The de-aging is distracting at first: The
actors' eyes look real, but their skin is
just a tad rubbery and flat — now and then
I had to stave off a PTSD flashback to Robert
Zemeckis' Polar Express.
But the special effects are hardly a deal
breaker, and in the end they probably add
to the movie's mythological vibe."
Mike Ryan at Uproxxx said that the de-aging
isn't perfect, but it's worth it, writing,
"This is the small price to pay to get all
these actors together again to tell this story."
Audiences can decide for themselves how they
feel about The Irishman when the film opens
in a limited capacity on November 1st, then
drops on Netflix on November 27th.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.